well Mark Imran Khan has been urging at
calm but he believes this is a
politically motivated move that they
swooped in to try and deliver these
arrest warrants because the opposition
the current government want to try and
avoid early elections something that he
has been pushing for ever since he lost
a no confidence vote back in last April
now Imran Khan also says he is prepared
for JL if indeed you will face that this
is not the first time that he's had this
looming threat of an arrest it's been a
protracted battle between the state and
him and his legal team as he tries to
avoid appearances in court he says
because it is simply too unsafe for him
that there is a security risk Imran Khan
of course faced an attempt on his life
in a container I was there at time he
survived that but he says there is still
a real threat to him but he wants to
urge calm at this moment though he is
prepared he says for his faith take a
listen to what he had to say to me a
little earlier
you're convinced are you that you will
be arrested yes I think they're very
determined this time we not only is the
police in heavy numbers but we also have
the Rangers I'm feeling like I'm in some
huge terrorist is is about to be a huge
oppression taking place to pick me up
which is bizarre I mean I've never I
mean this country has known me for 50
years so someone like me is being
treated today like uh I I guess some uh
lethal terrorist that's a the amount of
force outside they're doing everything
to get out of the elections or get me
out of the way
there is one way is to put me in jail
the other
is to have be killed I am a believer
you know who believes that life and
death is in all money to his hands so
I'm not really uh you know I I'm in that
way but fatalistic so if I have to go to
jail I will I'm mentally prepared I've
got my reading material ready
your critics say that you're playing a
game of cat and mouse here why not just
appear before the court and prevent what
could be a very violent episode in
Pakistan
I have remembered 80 cases against me
cases of blasphemy
uh cases are sedition
cases of murder
and then terrorism the problem is there
was no security
and the government itself the interior
Ministry has warned that my life is in
danger
so my lawyers asked the judges that look
if you want me to be appearing in courts
then at least provide security
do you think there is a real danger that
violence could erupt on the streets
now they put me in jail there is
obviously the workers are going to come
out when they come out if there is every
chance that somewhere along the line
there would be some violence now I have
told our workers that any violence does
not suit us because we want elections it
suits them we're trying to get out of
the elections I was on the container
with you when there was an attempt on
your life and now you face arrest
what is your strategy because this feels
like another very fraught moment for you
and Pakistan
well I'm you know I'm mentally prepared
already I mean they've been a few times
they've come to arrest me before too now
I'm mentally prepared uh
to go to jail today but um
uh what will happen after that I'm not
sure you know where it goes from there
we will my legal team is ready they will
go straight to the the high court
tomorrow and uh take up this uh this
nonsensical case and so we have the
legal team in place obviously we will
fight it legally